you ever seen a baby deer sometime if a
baby deer gets born they come out of
their mom first of all a baby deer walks
out backwards into the world do you know
that some animals come out frontwards
humans you know figures dude idiot
humans coming out front words what an
idiot because somebody can attack your
head immediately say you're being born
and there's a damn war going on or
there's a fire and you stick your head
out first what an idiot you're an idiot
and when I say you I mean all of us
because that's how we do it and that
should show us right there that humans
we're not it's you know it's not a we're
not really probe we're not we're kind of
just done a little we go headfirst into
the world
I mean it's brave you know it's
adventurous it's it's that pioneer
spirit but to a met think about this
you've there's it's a place you've never
been because you've never been anywhere
because you're brand new into the
universe as far as we know and you're
gonna stick your head out there first
what a damn Muppet what a greased-up
damn snicker sniffing Muppet it's crazy
and that's why I breach birthers I trust
a breach birth or more often and I wish
that if we should all have to wear a
little name tag that says if we were
breech or head first because while head
first it's brave and everything also way
idiot yeah never been in the universe
before I'm just gonna stick my head out
first Shh well that's nuts
so breech birth is at least alike and
we'll put a toe into the universe and
see how it feels maybe I'll put two feet
in the universe way more and if a breech
birth if it's a fire if it's a war or if
somebody lops their heads off their legs
off you still we still got the rest of
your body you can still get born
go live out in the world in a wheelchair
or on a skateboard if you don't have any
legs sometimes when people have legs you
know you can see on the internet it's a
lot of some men and some men and India
even they duct-tape them to a skateboard
and that's third body is the skateboard
you know they still have their chests
and their genitalia and hip you know
hips but but anyhow you know that's uh
that's kind of I was just fearful you
know I was just fearful I'll just get
you know I think just some fear that
there's a lot going on and that you know
and I was that I was just gonna mess up
you know that I just lost my confidence
I lost my footing for a second and and
going back to what I was talking about
and going back to what I was talking
about a baby deer they come in they back
into the universe if you ever is some
time I'll step at night watching animals
be born on the internet you know and I
was to watching funerals for a while but
my therapist said I said quit watching
funerals because it's depressing and
I'll say this dude honestly a lot of the
funerals on the Internet
extremely long like most of them are
Middle Eastern hey I'm talking you can
watch there's funerals on the internet
that are six hours long not and not very
bizarre exciting but also bizarre but um
you can watch babies be born but baby
deers they back into the universe but
when they get here their legs are so
shaky you know their legs are just like
just long you just they're almost just
like marshmallow with hoofs on the end
imagine trying to stand up on
marshmallow I mean it's tough it's
almost you know it's uh and sometimes if
you do a lot of drugs or something you
you can have that similar experience but
that's how baby deers are on their legs
shake and that's how I felt
I just felt shaky
I felt like my legs and my neck and
everything was just marshmallow and I
just got I just you know just felt like
I didn't want to I don't know I just
wanted I don't know I just didn't feel
okay and and some
you're gonna have days like that and so
that's just kind of what was going on
and I'm not apologizing I'm not
complaining I'm not I just was trying to
you know the past few days I was just
trying to think about what was going on
you know and sometimes [ __ ] you know
the universe is gonna be you know it's
gonna be this it's gonna be this cool
little crystal ball that I'm gonna play
with and look at and sometimes the
universe is gonna be a damn cannon ball
that's gonna rip right by and just rip
my sister's tits off you know or it's
gonna just just come steaming fast right
through my stepdaddy's legs and just
blast his nuts into the the next uh
nutus fear sometimes that kind of stuffs
gonna happen and that's what was going
on so I just had some fear man you know
I had some fear of of just failure I
guess I had some fear of you know I
don't know just everything that's some
fear so that's what was going on with me
and and today and today I'm feeling
better you know I've done some things I
went for a run I'm staying
I'm just staying confident I'm coming
back man I'm Stevie [ __ ] starlight
dude I'm not Billie black hole I'm not
Billie black hole dude I'm just just
just just falling into my own gravity
and I'm just gonna go hide in my shirt
like a Punxsutawney Phil that's lazy and
don't want to get out there and do his
work and see what his [ __ ] shadow is
gonna do I'm not gonna be like that I'm
gonna be like Stevie starlight and I'm
gonna [ __ ] when my mom is at work I'm
gonna go in her room and I'm gonna get
her nightgown out of the [ __ ] closet
and I'm gonna get in front of the mirror
and I'm gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna be human that's what I'm gonna
do thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz it's alarming